April is with us April is in Wisconsin
hi April how are you hi thank you for
taking my call
sure so um ever since I graduated high
school I made bad decision after bad
decision currently I am 29 with one and
a half year old and I filed and did my
whole bankruptcy last year so that's
over with that's behind me now I don't
want to dwell too much on the past that
I after listening to you I just found
you I feel like I could have done it had
I just done the right steps and and
known about it but again I don't want to
dwell too much and Dad my question for
you Dave um I only have ten thousand
dollars of student loans that I'd
obviously survived the bankruptcy so I
want to apply your teachings to my
current situation even though I didn't
do the steps noble would I be there at
the end here of baby steps to being that
I now have my I have just a little over
two thousand dollars for my security son
and and I own my own house that was one
of the only smart thing I ever did was
to own my little fixer-upper and it's
all good for my daughter and I and you
reaffirm he ran from you reaffirm the
mortgage in the bankruptcy and kept the
house so I bought that straight out of
cash it was a fixer-upper so we bought
it cash and we fixed it up and I live
there now okay
good for you okay yeah all right and you
did that I guess after the bankruptcy or
the the house was under Wisconsin law
gave you enough homestead exemption to
where they didn't take anybody yep yep I
got to keep it didn't go in the
bankruptcy at all so yeah I got to keep
that good okay what do you make a year I
make forty one thousand good okay so
I went through a bankruptcy when I was
your age it was larger and dumber than
yours because I was dumber than you and
I because I did stupid with zeros on the
end I have a PhD in D um B so I know
exactly how you feel is a little
different setting but it doesn't matter
it was a business deal but I just I was
dumb and you know I'm like you said I
made bad decisions and I reaped I reap
the whirlwind I reaped a hurricane in my
life and so I sewed stupid and I got
hurricanes right so um and that's kind
of what you went through so the thing I
want you to do is this and I'm you know
that was you know I was 28 years old and
I'm turning 60 this year so I was a long
time ago and yet today I don't want I
like what you said I don't want to dwell
on the past what I did at that time and
what I still do in a sense is I look at
the decisions that I made that put me
into bankruptcy and I want to pretty
much do the opposite right okay so the
only reason to revisit the bankruptcy is
not to shame yourself not to feel
condemned by your past and that kind of
a thing but what I what I the reason to
revisit it is to root to kind of do a
CSI on the patient figure out why he
died you know why that's why this
financial situation died I killed it now
what did I do that killed it right and
so I you know I figured out I don't
borrow money anymore
I figured out I didn't have any money
for savings I figured out I wasn't
living on a budget I figured out I was
doing everything the opposite of what I
teach today and so I went broke well no
kiddin you know and so what you want to
do is say okay here's the three dumbest
things I did why did I do those and why
will I never do them again and then put
a lock on it and leave it in the past so
learn from it's all you really want to
do and then and then no condemnation no
shaming on that and we move forward
because the rear view mirror in the car
is smaller
then the windshield the windshield is
graced the rearview mirror is looking
back at the stupid stuff we've done it
doesn't need to be too big no one spent
too much time there but enough that we
don't cut over into that Lane and knock
somebody out in the ditch right so all
we got to say that's that's what I would
do there and there's a real good mental
health kind of feeling to that a
emotional health kind of feeling to that
spiritual health kind of feeling to that
to get them get them get the get the
good stuff out of the pain and then
leave the pain back there that's what I
like to think of it like I gave my
daughter and I our first start a very
old debt no but if you do a fresh start
and you keep doing the same stuff and
didn't learn anything the fresh start
doesn't count because you're right back
into the soup so you got it you got to
change direction you know you have to
repent that's what a Christian would
call it turn another direction okay so
all of that now then where are you you
are in baby step two you have $10,000 in
debt you make $45,000 a year you have a
paid-for house you need to get your debt
paid off and then you need to build an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses and so you need to get on every
dollar and you need to get into
Financial Peace University and finish
learning the lessons that take you into
a positive future away from a negative
past that's where you are so hold on
we're gonna sign you up we're gonna help
out a single mom here that little girl
got a new life a fresh start
let's put her on solid ground I'll put
you into Financial Peace University the
one-year membership the class every
dollar plus all the communities all that
stuff's gonna be there to help you it's
going to rock your world kiddo